parler de concentration des richesses
c'est tout à fait exact j'en parle dans
mon livre je suis le premier à mon
alarme et il ya beaucoup d'effets qui
joue sur cette concentration d'abord la
croissance de la taille des marchés qui
fait que la croissance début des plus
gros de fortes des plus grosses fortunes
vont souvent avec dans l'histoire c'est
souvent corrélée à la taille des marchés
bon et puis il ya un effet tout bête
c'est que cette création monétaire
massive
vous savez qu'elle a une conséquence et
qu'elle fait monter le prix des actifs
donc les gens font pas d'actifs c zéro
et quand vous avez des actifs
c'est-à-dire l'immobilier ou évidemment
des actifs financiers
eh bien ces actifs augmente c'est ce
qu'on voit d'ailleurs en ce moment avec
une bourse que jamais été aussi haute et
puis l'immobilier qui continue ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une bulle mais on sait
pas vraiment si ça va exploser ou pas
parce que c'est là que se retrouvent
cette création monétaire extraordinaire
donc ça c'est un autre problème sur
lequel il faut ouvrir les yeux donc en
effet il faut pas être dogmatique sur le
montant d'une dette et aujourd'hui je
crois vraiment les dépenses de l'état et
l'importance des dépenses de l'état qui
a été fait pour soutenir le coc vide
était nécessaire en revanche il faut
faire très attention parce que le
retournement peut arriver sur qui un
jour la signature de la france peut en
effet être dégradée les inquiétudes
peuvent remonter l'écart de taux par
rapport à ce qu'on demande sur les taux
allemands par exemple peut monter pour
d'autres pays vous ai cités l'italie par
exemple ou pour évidemment parler de la
grèce satin quiétude et et peut arriver
et un moment donné il faut faire
attention à ce que les gens puissent
changer d'avis sur sur la dette
vous savez que si la signature de la
france aujourd'hui si bonne si on nous
prête si facilement c'est parce que les
gens en confiance dans la capacité du
système fiscal est dans la force de la
france encore aujourd'hui d'aller
finalement continuer à rembourser mais
attention car l'élastique ce temps
jusqu'au jour où une casse voilà ça j'ai
pas l'impression d'aider raisonnable en
disant ça moi j'ai plutôt l'impression
que celui qui pense à l'argent magique
sans fin et au fait qu'on puisse et on
n'a pas fait ça austérité mais le fait
de dépenser plus qu'on a il ya un moment
donné où je suis désolé je suis
peut-être bouché à l'émeri mais je ne
vois pas comment ça peut fonctionner
[Musique]